[Musica]
ho pensato a lungo che cosa significasse
essere peerless e dopo l'olio imbarazzo
di auto dell'università ligustro che
secondo me nessuno e senza paura
semplicemente abbiamo paura diverse
ho constatato che sono qualcosa che
abbiamo attivamente affrontato possiamo
dire di non tenerla più e cosa significa
che per essere fearless senza paura
bisogna essere stati a un certo punto
fearful con paura e di aver preso
proprio quella paura ed aver avuto la
lungimiranza di trasformarla in una
forza tante volte queste paure neanche
se ne vanno del tutto rimangono ma
chiamarle ad alta voce ci aiuta
visualizzarle modo da poterle
riaffrontare poi un secondo momento
detto così sembra anche facile no invece
non lo è anche perché tutti noi abbiamo
delle paure diversi in base alle nostre
dimensioni cioè quello che per me è una
cosa terrorizzante per te può essere un
gioco le ragazze e viceversa ma non per
questo una cosa e mi hanno importante
dell'altra perché noi teniamo anche
spesso a minimizzare i problemi degli
altri perché per noi non sono importanti
perché in quel momento noi stiamo
vivendo qualcosa di peggio no ma
dobbiamo ricordarci che vivere il
proprio percorso è un nostro sacrosanto
diritto
tante volte io mi sono sentita dire ma
che i problemi vuoi avere ai tutto è la
strada spianata e tutto no questo vuol
dire che è come se arrivasse una persona
a te cara a chiederti una mano perché
quel momento sta male ma tu nella tua
testa servendo qualcosa di peggiore e
quindi lui non si merita il tuo aiuto
non si merita neanche di soffrire deve
ridimensionare la sua sofferenza in base
a che questo non può avvenire perché
siamo umani siamo diversi e ci vuole un
po di empatia
secondo me si può imparare iniziando a
smetterla di sentire le cose basta ma
inizierà ad ascoltarle allora io quando
avevo 18 anni aveva una sola certezza
volevo andare a vivere a londra finire
il liceo e studiare di in quel periodo
tutto profumava di nuovo avete presente
quel prof
di nuovo che inebria le narici io volevo
quella libertà che brava o da tantissimo
tempo e soprattutto volevo comprarmi del
tempo per capire chi fossi io veramente
no perché diciott'anni sì a tutti e sia
nessuno e quando arrivò la lettera in
cui mi dissero che non ne avevano preso
nella mia università dei sogni quella
certezza si sgretolò completamente ma
qualche giorno dopo ricevetti una
proposta lavorativa che ai tempi presi
come un segno del destino che ci provino
mi presero per diventare la nuova
conduttrice di xfactor day ovvero la
fascia pomeridiana quotidiana loro mi
presero e io ho preso una decisione che
mi cambiò la vita completamente lo che
ci con la tranquillità tipica dei 18
anni ma inconsapevolmente quella
decisione incorporare se tutte le mie
più profonde paure perché accettando di
espormi sta completamente accettando la
cattiveria delle persone e per una
persona come me che ha la fissa di
piacere sempre a tutti forse per poter
piacere di più a se stessa è il modo più
diretto e traumatico per interfacciarsi
con le sue insicurezze e la mia storia
non è quella di una persona che è stata
buttata nel mondo dello spettacolo e la
mia sorella di una bambina che è
cresciuta è nata e cresciuta sotto il
riflettore che ha dovuto imparare a
conoscere questo riflettore negli anni
ad odiarlo amarlo a combatterlo e poi
alla fine abbandonarci sì perché era
inevitabile una bambina che ha sempre
apprezzato il lavoro e la passione la
dedizione e sacrificio dei suoi genitori
che conosce la perfezione e backstage di
un palazzetto l'odore di un teatro dopo
un'esibizione il brivido di un applauso
una bambina che a un certo punto quando
non era più bambina ha iniziato a
sognare di salirci su quel palco ma no
non si può perché in questo paese deve
dimostra il doppio auree ricordatelo e
quindi quella quel sogno è stato preso
cartonato messo in un angolo
e sono stati creati nuovi sogni per
compensare quello dei sogni meno
rischiosi meno paurosi meno dannosi per
lei ma quel sogno non è mai andato via è
sempre rimasto lì ma torniamo al momento
decisivo
ok è agosto 2015
finalmente può iniziare la mia
esperienza è stato comunicato ovunque io
ricevo migliaia e migliaia centinaia di
messaggi con delle cattiverie mai viste
prima neanche la loro mai viste e tra le
tante badanti sul t c'era questa parola
che conosciamo tutti raccomandata
io all'epoca non sapevo neanche che cosa
significasse tanto che mi ricordo che
andai a google harlow e a defezioni di
raccomandazione era intercessione in
favore di una persona al fine di
ottenere qualcosa che le sarebbe
impossibile o difficile conseguire con i
mezzi propri ma io sapessi nessuno era
interceduto per me anzi sapessero quanto
era stato difficile dirlo a mio padre
trovare la forza di dirglielo e lui
aveva un programma completamente diverso
per me io stessa non sapevo che l'avrei
fatto fino al giorno prima quindi era
possibile che si fossero sbagliati
e invece no scoprire più avanti che
quella parola veniva comunemente usata
inglesi dice messi usl mal usata per
definire i figli di che volevano entrare
a far parte del mondo dello spettacolo
no e io quella parola non lascio la
criticano la città
più di ogni altra critica che mi era mai
stata fatta anche sull'aspetto fisico
che forse a livello psicologico ancora
adesso mi accompagna ma più di ogni
altra cosa non lo accettava in una
capivo fortunatamente però andò tutto
liscio fila tutto liscio
adesso ad oggi quella parola sento
sempre di meno forse perché negli anni
se c'è una cosa che ho imparato è che
non devi permettere a nessuno di
definirti e questo non significa che le
persone non possono esprimere la loro
opinione
significa che tu lo devi andare a
cercare i consensi dove sai che non li
troverai se riesci non li devi cercare
proprio
insomma la mia strada cominciava a
delinearsi e crescendo sentivo di
desiderare fortemente l'indipendenza per
questo nel 2017 avevo già iniziato mio
percorso è uscita di casa da sola
livorno fidanzatino studiarlo insomma
avevo trovato la mia dimensione mi
ricorderò sempre che era una tranquilla
giornata di marzo io mi stavo avviando
verso la meta delle cuffiette nelle
orecchie stavo camminando l'ha pure una
bella giornata
insomma ero in pace con livelli avete
presente quei momenti in cui si è in
pace con l'universo e ricevette una
telefonata di mia madre a orizzonti
allarmare ma abbiamo ricevuto una
lettera di minacce degli assolutamente
venire a casa subito
io vi risparmio i dettagli della mia
paura in quel momento ma mi ricordo
perfettamente che quella sensazione in
quel momento che io provai mi accompagno
nei mesi successivi ed era di non
sentirmi più assicuro cioè il momento
prima era una ragazza spensierata e
secondo pero letteralmente paralizzata
dalla paura nel giro di una giornata
avevo scoperto che qualcuno voleva
acidificare mi e l'avrebbero fatto o il
giorno stesso o cinque anni dopo questo
c'era scritto nella legge
che la mia tanto bramata libertà era
andata a farsi benedire e che a suo
posto aveva guadagnato una guardia del
corpo
di lì in avanti dove ti lidl finire
tutte le mie priorità
sergio la guardia del corpo mi seguiva
ogni passo che che facevo schematizza è
la mia vita rock e per una ventenne una
cosa molto difficile da fare dovevo
definire gli orari le cose che dovevo
fare non avevo più una libertà non
potevo andare in certi posti affollati
perché sergio non si sentiva di poter
fare il suo lavoro giustamente tante
volte neanche lo chiamavo rinunciavo
alle cose perché mi sentivo in colpa a
ad avere una persona che rispondesse
alle mie esigenze miei bisogni no quindi
imparare a mettere in linea le priorità
però in tutto ciò non sentivo giustizia
in quello che stava succedendo mi
sentivo vittima di una cosa che che non
aveva senso di esistere nessuno mi
poteva aiutare proprio in quel momento
che io avevo bisogno più che mai di uno
scopo un po quella fase mi ricorda
quest'anno che abbiamo vissuto tutti
quanti no quella sensazione di
incertezza ma soprattutto di impotenza
davanti a quello che sta succedendo era
la stessa airlock da un nella mia vita
e proprio in quel momento entrò a far
parte della mia vita allo sport e anche
li chiamiamo la chiamiamo la coincidenza
però era come se destino mi stesse
comunicando qualcosa per gli operai e
avevo cercato di avvicinare nello sport
che tra l'altro andava contro ogni fibra
della mia essenza perché ero l'anti
sport per antonomasia e non c'ero mai
riuscita in quel momento fu lo sport ad
avvicinarsi a me e io passai dal da
essere una persona che viveva sul divano
a essere l'anti sport a una che si
sveglia alle sei del mattino per andare
a correre per per sentirsi più
realizzata da ho trovato uno scopo avevo
trovato un obiettivo
e fu proprio lì che mi resi conto che
di momenti bui che succedono anche
raccomandati votate bene
sei tu che ti crei la tua luce alla fine
del tunnel e la mia luce fu la corsa ma
la corsa ragazzi non si fa dal suo e la
corsa difficile la corsa e sofferenza e
dolore è tosta e la corsa è la cosa più
fearless che ci sia
secondo me perché tu scegliendo la
sceglie anche di combattere contro la
cosa più ostacolante della tua vita
quella cosa che ti ostacolerà
quotidianamente per sempre te stesso e
per una come me che ha dovuto sempre
combattere per essere se stessa come un
parallelismo alla vita perché ho sempre
dovuto combattere contro me stessa
contro gli altri contro il giudizio
contro la definizione che mi davano
contro la consapevolezza di non essere
mai abbastanza per poi capire che è
inutile cercare di convincere gli altri
che si sbagliano che non è vero che sono
raccomandata che non è vero che sono
brutta grassa snob antipatica incapace
che non è vero che me la tiro è inutile
sapete perché perché solo noi possiamo
sapere chi siamo nessun altro si può
definire solo noi abbiamo la possibilità
di trasformare le nostre paure in forze
perché solo guardandoci dentro possiamo
affrontare quello che c'è là fuori